the british government has announced its
banning the chinese tech giant huawei
from building the uk's
next generation 5g network it's a major
u-turn that could provoke a severe
retaliation from china
rt's isa ali picks up the story for us
the united kingdom announcing in a
stunning u-turn that the chinese company
huawei
will not be allowed to provide uk
mobile phone providers with their
technology and their equipment going
forward from the end of december this
year
and that those uk providers must remove
all huawei
5g kit from their networks by 2027
and with the number of those within the
uk government
stating national security concerns but
of course
this is a company which has long since
been providing the uk
with 2g technology 3g technology 4g
technology
all of which don't uh come under this
latest
uh decision to remove technology those
pieces of technology can stay
but it would appear that pressure from
the united states which is long opposed
to wireless involvement in the 5g
network has
finally come to bear is our security
policy
being led by the us the reality mr
speaker
is that the original decision on railway
was made because over the past decade
this government has
failed to deliver a sustainable plan for
our digital economy
we still have a major job upgrading our
digital infrastructure
will the minister make clear what extra
measures he will take to ensure that we
don't fall
further behind our competitors in terms
of 5g and gigabyte capable broadband
due to disruption caused by this
decision this and the delay to 5g
reflects a a long-term failure of uk
telecom strategy to anticipate what the
country would need
and to prepare for it now we heard
oliver dowden earlier the digital
secretary
referring to national security as one of
the reasons
as to this decision by the united
kingdom but earlier this year
the uk said that they had reviewed
hawaii in january
and decided that everything was fine
that the intelligence stated that there
was no threat
from the chinese telecom giant the boris
johnson asking
if not hawaii then which company could
provide that equipment
the british public deserve to have
access to the best possible
technology if people oppose one brand or
another
then they have to tell us which is the
what's the alternative
the united states have long been trying
to pressure countries that have taken
huawei's 5g technology on board and
trying to convince them
to drop all of that technology but the
chinese have responded in the wake
of that uk decision saying that there
will be repercussions going forward
regrettably our future in the uk has
become politicized
this is about u.s trade policy and not
security
over the past 20 years huawei has
focused on building a better connected
uk
as a responsible business we will
continue to support our customers
as we have always done we will conduct a
detailed review
of what today announcement means for our
business here
and we'll work with the uk government to
explain how we can continue to
contribute to a better connected
britain now all of this of course takes
place in the context of the united
kingdom which is hurtling towards the no
deal brexit
and has stated repeatedly that they want
to open up to the world and to seek
trade
with all of the economies of the world
the chinese being one of the biggest of
course
this could have serious consequences for
a united kingdom
which says it's seeking to broaden its
horizons
you